I was wondering about using an electric blanket with the right machine involved under the blanket.
Is there a problem with doing that? I've concerned about the wavelength in the electricity
running through the blanket. So there is not a problem with using an electric blanket or an electric
heating pad with the right machine. It won't interrupt the frequencies. The dirty electricity
or the EMS that you might get from the electric heating pad or electric blanket are going to be far
surpassed by the right frequency. So there's not a problem there. There's argument, though, whether
there's health benefits that can or health negative effects that could take place using an electric
blanket. Now there's people on one side of the spectrum that says that it's very bad for you
because it's creating a different circuit that can affect your body's electric field and using an
electric blanket is not good for you. And then there's people on the way on the other side of the
spectrum that says that's a bunch fully nonsense of a much newer page weirdos. I found probably in the
middle of that. I don't use electric blanket because I'm concerned about the EMS production of the
electric. I never we don't have electric blankets. I've never been able to test it with the EMS meter,
but you know there's concern there. The reason why I like our electric heating pads that we sell
is because they use those those terminally discs in them. So they're not producing EMS like a regular
heating coiled heating pad is. So you're getting some better wavelengths in that that you are
getting from a coiled heating pad. But I understand that some people just have to use an electric blanket
because they're crazy to death. They have, you know, you do want to investigate maybe why you would
need to use an electric blanket. Do you have frequent overlays in all these lab videos, but you know what
would be reasons why I'm cold all the time and I'm freezing is it because maybe I just keep my temperature
down and where I spouse likes the temperature down in the house and it's very cold. Well extra blankets
should work for that. Well no I don't care how many blankets and I am I'm still freezing. We need to
assess thyroid function to get into complete thyroid panel. Most commonly though it would be
low blood values as far as red blood cells go and that is called ademia. So a CBC complete blood
would be the test to analyze that. If you haven't had blood work for a long time consider getting
our complete wellness panel. If you don't have the ability to get insurance coverage through getting
your doctor to order it. Our complete wellness panel has CBC complete metabolic panel, multiple other
tests that are great value and a complete thorough thyroid evaluation and it's $132 plus whatever
it's paid for your blood draw pretty darn inexpensive. So consider getting that done. But no it will not
affect the right frequencies.